So the Dallas,
for example,
they represent the world
in terms that are quite similar to
those that I just described for you.
So that the doubt central
Dow assemble is this one,
the Yin Yang symbol and Yang
basically stands for order.
That's what it means.
But it means all the things
that I've listed there.
It means order masculinity,
the daytime,
the known,
it also means
authoritarianism and fascism.
And then yen on the
opposite side is chaos.
Femininity,
the night,
the unknown decadence denialism.
And it's also a relationship between
the conscious and unconscious.
The current consciousness
is represented by light.
And the reason for that is,
well,
when are you conscious?
Your conscious during the day,
right?
Cause we're,
we're,
we're creatures that live in the day.
Unlike rats for example,
you know,
they live at night.
So for us,
consciousness is associated
with enlightenment and
illumination and daytime and
sunrise and the,
and the bright noon sky.
And the unconscious is
associated with the nighttime.
And the reason for that partly too is
that your unconscious is actually a lot
more active at night.
First of all,
that's when you dream.
And it's also the time when,
if you're frightened of something or
if you're depressed and ruminative the
frightening thoughts and the depressing
and ruminative thoughts are going to
come up.
So many,
many people have the experience
of waking up in a kind of,
cause I called sweat at three
in the morning and having,
you know,
nothing but it continual stream
of worries run through their head.
And there's pretty good evidence that a
lot of what you're doing at night when
you sleep,
when you're dreaming and when you're not
dreaming is actually processing threat,
you know?
But most of the time you
were asleep for that.
Sometimes you wake up
during it and it's like,
yeah,
it's not something you really
want to be conscious about.
You know,
it's,
it's hard on you.
And it's very,
very common among people
who are depressed,
you know?
So if you want to diagnose
someone for depression,
one of the things you ask them is,
well,
is your sleep chopped up?
You know,
do you wake up multiple times
at night and when you wake up,
what happens if they say,
well you know I have worries running
through my head and I can't stop them.
That's rumination cause it's,
it's an automatic process.
It's an unconscious process.
Then you know that the balance between
positive and negative emotion has shifted
too far for that person.
There's so much chaos and
pain in their life or their,
their emotional systems have become
dysregulated that it's starting to pop up
into consciousness and dominated.
So now the Yin Yang symbol is interesting
for a variety of other reasons too
because the dow is believed that that
symbol represents being now being is not
the same thing as objective reality being
is what you experience has a conscious
creature that's being and for the Dow is
being is made up of these two elements,
order in chaos.
And the reason for that,
it's quite straight forward.
The reason for that is wherever you go
and whenever you live and whoever you
are,
each environment that you're
in is composed of things
you understand and things
that work the way you expect them
to and things you do not understand.
And that can be,
that can pull the rug out
from you at any moment.
And so you can say in some sense that
these symbolic representations are
representations of the most
unchanging elements of Ba.
So the most real things,
because you know,
a typical modern person
look at this and think,
well those aren't real.
It's like they are real.
In fact,
they're hyper real.
Because one of the things that defines
real is that it's permanent and it is
permanent.
No matter where you go,
there are things you know
and things you don't know.
And it doesn't matter who you are,
it's permanent.
So it's part of the existential
landscape of human being.
Now the other thing that's,
there's two other things that are quite
cool about the Yin Yang symbol in one is
that the,
each of the black pacey
has little white.in it.
And the White Paisley
has a little black.in it.
And the reason for that is the Taoists
also recognized quite well that chaos
could turn to order at any moment.
You know,
so a new order can arise out of a
chaotic structure that's like a,
that's a revolution in some sense.
But by the same token,
if you're in a place that's
orderly and predictable,
something can happen that casts you
into a chaotic situation right away.
So there's a dynamic,
even though these two
things oppose each other,
in some sense,
there's a continual dynamic
interplay between them.
And then the final thing that's
quite interesting about this symbol,
this is mindbogglingly brilliant idea,
is that cause the dao also means that
the way and the way is the line between
the two.
And so what that indicates is,
this is a brilliant idea,
is that the optimal position for a
human being isn't in chaos or in order.
Because if it's too much order,
then it's totalitarian.
And if it's too much chaos than it's
disgust and fear and emotional pain and
depression.
So where's the proper place and the
Dallas answers right on the line where you
have one foot in order so that you're
fairly stable and you'll have another foot
in chaos.
So that new and interesting and compelling
and transforming things are happening
to you.
And one of the things that you might note
is that your nervous system basically
tells you when you're there and the way
it tells you is by making you interested
in whatever it is that you're engaged in.
Because the fact that the thing
that you're engaged in grips you,
which is really an unconscious process,
you can't really control that.
It's something that happens to you
is because your nervous system,
which is actually adapted
to the environment of chaos
and order is telling you
that if you're engaged in interested,
you are at in the place where the
balance between chaos and order is,
is perfect.
Now you think about that,
it's no use reading a paper that
you cannot understand at all.
Even though hypothetically that would
be a tremendously informative paper,
right?
But you can't understand it
because it's all chaos to you.
And then there's absolutely
no reason reading a paper,
the tense time.
If you've extracted the
information out of it,
it's going to be boring.
Okay,
so what do you want?
Well,
you want a paper that you
can almost understand.
So there's,
you know,
you're,
you're the frameworks,
the cognitive frameworks that you have
at hand are sufficient for you to take
the next step into the unknown.
And the paper will,
will inform you of that.
And so those are the sorts of things.
Books do that.
Movies do that conversations do that
even lines of thought to that if they're
exactly at the right level
of complexity for you,
they're going to engage you.
And people know this man.
They know it.
So here's an example.